and then officially start
all right welcome to the tdp seminar
everyone before we introduce our invited
speakers let's go over some rules and
logistics as usual first of all please
mute yourself during the talk unless you
have questions
if you do have questions you are welcome
to unmute and ask otherwise please use
chat room to post your questions so that
we can address them in q and a session
at the end
second today's ddps seminar is open to
external audiences therefore
no classified discussion is allowed so
please watch out finally the talk today
will be recorded and uploaded in our
youtube channel that's about it now let
me introduce our speaker today
uh it is an honor to host eagle uh mesut
who is a distinguished professor at the
university of california santa barbara
he pursues research in the fields of
artificial intelligence dynamic
dynamical systems control theory and
applications to security energy
efficient design and operations in
complex systems
he did his phd ph d in dynamical systems
in caltech
dr mezrich
was a post-doctoral researcher at the
mathematics institute's university of
warwick in uk
from 2019 uh 2000 um
not 2000 1994 to 95
and from 1995 to 1999 he was a member of
college of engineering at the uc santa
barbara barbara
from 2000 to 2001 he has worked as an
associate professor at harvard
university in the division of
engineering and applied sciences
he won numerous awards just to name a
few he won the alfred sloan fellowship
and nsf courier award and
george alex um
xb outstanding paper award from i triple
e he also won the united technology
senior vice president for science and
technology special achievement price in
and
many more
dr mesit is the director of the center
for energy efficient design and head of
buildings and
design solutions group at the institute
for energy efficiency at the uc santa
barbara
he holds
10 u.s patents he founded
in ending
in 2003 and is the cto and chief
scientist of mixed mode ai
today igor
will talk about kugman operator theory
which is really popular these days
for
dynamical systems control and data
analytics which is very interesting
topic
now without further ado let me pass the
button to igor by asking one question as
usual today's question is what is your
favorite thing to do other than research
ah that's an easy question
music
or music oh yeah
are you do you compose music or
play music or all of it i was brought up
in a in a musical family and uh
my mom taught me instruments when i was
very young so i i kept it as a passion
all my life
guitar mostly but some piano as well
and guitar and other instruments i
cannot i cannot play any wind
instruments
those are too hard
see i see well someday i want to hear
that
in person
okay it's all yours the stage is all
yours all right well
first of all thanks thanks very much for
this invitation
it's a it's a pleasure uh to talk here
i've been to
uh
lawrence livermore once
in the past and it was it was fun uh a
couple of days of discussion it was a
long time ago so i'm i'm happy to be
back
i'll talk today about
equipment operator theory in general
but i'd like to point out
you know a few things that are happening
these days as young so
pointed out
it's becoming a pretty large field
um
i think there are two directions that
are becoming
really really interesting in this
context and i'd like to emphasize them
one of them is in direction of control
expansions in direction of control
theory
and the other one is expansion in in
context of learning and i'd like to
advocate that
for dynamical processes
this provides us with a with a very nice
uh framework for learning so i'll try to
show you um examples examples of that
um
let me see if i can move okay so um
let me speak briefly about
sort of the core aspects
um
kubeman operator theory is a
reformulation of dynamical systems
theory that stems from
poincare's work originally the dynamical
systems theory it's a reformation in
terms of evolutionary observables i'll
go through uh through this in some
detail
coupon and for neumann used it to study
measure preserving systems in
mathematics you're going to find
a coupon operator named composition
operator actually it predates kupman as
far as the definition
is concerned as as the composition
operator there is something that's
called a shaffer that that is in effect
an equation that describes the
action on the uh kupman operator
the the
starting interest in this was um
the spectral analysis you will see that
the operator is linear and so
you know any self-respecting scientist
or mathematician when they see a linear
operator
or a matrix they go for um
for its spectra eigenvalues and and
eigenvectors in which in this case
they're eigen functions
um the operators are non-self-adjoint
though so this comes from quantum
mechanics but in quantum mechanics you
have
the inspiration for this was quantum
mechanics but quantum mechanics usually
deals with self-adjoint operators
but in dynamical systems this helps us
to
unravel the state space geometry and and
originally i thought about it as as a
way of
you know enabling model reduction as
well
but um
it's proven
also as
to a certain extent i suspected early on
that linear control methods can be used
for controlling high dimensional systems
that are non-linear in fact so this
combination of model reduction and
control i think is these days becoming
very interesting and then also the
relationship to data analysis is very
direct so as opposed to geometrical
theories which you know the the analysis
data analysis is harder from from that
perspective
because essentially the numerical
methods are algebraic
um relationship to data analysis is is
very organic and so in that sense it's
similar to a stochastic process here
actually sometimes i refer to it as
basically non-stationary stochastic
process theory
um
let's see further
so
um what was the focus
uh
in the in the last let's say 20 years
the focus has really been
you know away from the original coupon
and phenomenal ideas to dissipate even
hybrid systems because they originally
considered only conservative systems
think hamiltonian systems
we have a lot of high dimensional
applications
power grids fluids building dynamics
that i'm
actually quite interested in myself
molecular dynamics
i'm going to show you today an
interesting application which we did
with darpa support which is game
dynamics
and then network security there is
really you know
mixed mod that ais is a company that
actually has
um taken these types of ideas and
applied them in network security
successfully so
a pretty broad range of applications uh
it's a uniform mathematical framework
for both random
stochastic dynamical systems hybrid
dynamical systems and and deterministics
so it doesn't
it doesn't really
stay within the realm strictly of
deterministic dynamical systems that
kugman and for deterministic hamiltonian
dynamical systems that coupman and for
neumann envisioned we've gone pretty
pretty far beyond it and then
i think the most interesting
type of application today is in learning
and ai
and so i'll i'll show you some examples
of that and and tell you how
you know whether the differentiating
factors there on the left what you're
seeing is is an original application
um
where uh what what you're looking at is
the stream wise streaming component
of a flow getting out of a circular
orifice this is used for for example
cooling jet engines
where the the the flow out of jet engine
is going in this direction so there is a
cross flow and this jet is coming out
um think of it as
also smoke coming out of the chimney but
it's really a cooling of a jet engine
application and so the purpose of this
movie is to to show you this is a it
looks like a very much a random
dynamical process
but it turns out that if you find
eigen values of
of uh
this operator
that i mentioned
that you end up having
so here are these bright dots blue and
red are actually eigenvalues you end up
having finding structures that look very
very coherent in this uh
messy flow
so that's kind of the basic idea and
i'll tell you a little bit more about
the splitting about the coherent and
coherent and non-coherent part of the
part of dynamics as we go so another
little part of introduction
is here
um originally
dynamical systems were taught in in the
context of then of ordinary differential
equations this is kind of a newton's
point of view
and if one is lucky and in particular if
we have a simple enough system
in this case uh my spring system
uh one can solve the equations
analytically
now of course in general this is not
possible that led to the whole evolution
in chaos theory revolution in chaos
theory uh some
many ordinary differential equations
even in 3d don't have
explicit closed form solutions so
what poincare introduced is this picture
of state versus state rather than state
versus time
and so that led to whole dynamical
system geometric theory but there is a
third point of view which is spectral
that wiener introduced you know well you
could go all the way to fourier of
course
back but we were introduced during the
second world war and after that and the
a really interesting aspect of this that
plays with equipment operator theory is
that
there is a single plot here in the power
spectral density so here is the
frequency is the here is the amplitude
and the power
and there if there is a single line we
immediately know that if we know that
particular frequency omega n and if we
know the amplitude and phase of the
evolution we can reconstruct the signal
so if you wish to look at the first
encoder uh in the history of machine
learning it's right here
that's how i like to look at it now
cooper and for neumann
um
were interested in the following idea
a
y x
you know position and momentum for
example for for dynamical systems
energy of course is is a really
important observable and yet the the
primitive equations are not written in
terms of energy
so why not ask you know what is the
general evolution for any arbitrary
observable and then try to find the ones
that are better or rather simpler in
describing the motion
than
than maybe your original ones
energy is a particular example here if
we were to write an equation of
evolution for energy in this system it
would be just e dot is equal to zero the
energy doesn't change for the mass
spring system without uh without damping
so um so they wrote the formalism for
conservative systems or hamiltonian
systems that extended that and basically
wrote down an operator that i'm going to
describe
next so the idea is
suppose you have an observable on the
state space m
and you have a mapping this is a
discrete time mapping here is a
continuous time mapping this would be a
solution of an ordinary differential
equation
then if you compose the observable f
with the
mapping
and
say that's a new function of x
then you can say well
i took a function f
and i produced a new function
and it's easy to see that that operation
is linear just put f1 plus f2 here the
composition
ports through
um
and you see that the operation is linear
so u itself is a linear operator of
composition with the map
here in continuous time it's a
composition with the with the flaw
so that's the idea in original appeared
in 31 and 32
uh carleman was
some of you might know about carlin
linearization carloman was second to
arrive at this idea uh coupon was first
carmen was aware of this and pointed out
that someone told him that kupman
already had that particular idea before
to remove a little bit of mystique if
you have a x dot is equal to f of x for
those of you that know a vection
equation in fluids the generator for
these evolutions
is actually an an um advection equation
with a kind of wrong sign
so um if you ported this to the
left-hand side there would be a there
would be a minus here so it's a it's a
forward-looking rather than a backwards
looking uh equation why is that because
this composition says if i'm at point x
i go forward one step
and i looked at the value of f at that
forward step and then i bring it back
right
it's a pullback operation
uh while the usual advection equation
looks at what's coming in what kind of
densities are coming in that's the
duality
and then again that's a linear operator
this is the linear family of operators
so
you can ask what are the eigen functions
in this case and if you work from the
generator side
and you say okay if we assume that this
evolves um as e to the lambda t
in time this should remind you a little
bit of quantum mechanics
then uh then this is the equation that
phi and lambda need to satisfy in order
to be eigen function eigenvalue for this
equation
on the operator side it just says that
the evolution of phi this particular
observable so now we chose one
is e to the lambda t phi of x so
spatially the observable doesn't change
its amplitude changes so eigenfunctions
are
special functions simple functions and
their evolution is basically governed by
linear equations because this thing on
the left
is really phi dot so so the equation for
an eigen function is phi dot is lambda
phi
this is why it's often said or
or rather it should be said usually it's
said that coupon operator is a linear
global linearization tool but what is
more important in my view is that it
provides you with finite dimensional
reduction to a linear system
if you find phi even for a non-linear
system
this is going to give you a
representation of the evolution of that
function
even for a
a one-dimensional evolution that is very
simple and linear
so the methodology is capable in certain
cases of producing finite dimensional
linear equivalence of nonlinear systems
using special observables like
eigenfunctions
what do we get out of that well part of
it is geometry of
geometry of
level sets of kupman functions in state
space
and then
if we do projections of vector valued
observables
they are going to give us equipment
modes
and
in general very often you don't
necessarily want to exhibit the operator
and you'd like to get eigenfunctions
directly from data
without
really representing the operator
representing the operator might be a
hard thing to do and i'll talk about it
in the next slide as to how you can
but some of my original work was dealing
with finding eigenfunctions and
eigenvalues
directly from data
without exhibiting the operator and
the nice thing about the equipment
operator
formalism is that this is actually
possible you don't need to know what the
operator is
in order to construct its eigen
functions directly from evolution
if that sounds strange and magical it
actually isn't you don't need to know a
matrix
in order to find this eigenvector if if
its eigenvector is for example
uh
coinciding with
a positive real eigenvalue then it's
enough
to
uh know the evolution of an arbitrary
vector because it's going to align with
that eigenvector over a long time
uh and it's enough to rescale the final
result in order to get an eigenvector so
uh in in the same sense
although much trickier because
the equipment uh spectrum is usually
contained within the unit circle
and within within the unit circle
that means that you have oscillatory
dynamics and this example that i gave of
a matrix cannot be
ported in a simple way but that's
exactly
where some of the
methodology uh sits so
um i i won't say much more about this if
anybody's interested in you know the
methodologies of finding the the spectra
and eigenfunctions directly from data
without exhibiting the operator happy to
talk about it
after the talk
but um
let's let's talk briefly about what does
it mean to actually exhibit the operator
i have an abstract
point p and then you have um let's say p
prime
which is the next point that the
dynamics in the state space
takes you to
and let's say that you decided to
describe that evolution by some set of
functions that we labeled by bold face
x so the x prime which is the x
associated with p prime is some
nonlinear mapping of x let's say let's
say we have a closed set of equations
as i said
these might be positions in momenta and
we might decide that we instead would
like to use
some other functions to describe the
evolution
so let's say we produce a basis of
functions fj on this
on this
state space
then we can represent the original
states
as a sum
over some coefficients times fj
and here is the space that we embed it
into so these observables get
live in their own space and so we have a
point in that space now let's act with u
on an individual basis
function so u f j in many cases if you
choose an appropriate space for
operation of u
can be represented essentially as a
matrix these are again basis functions
and this is djk
so that's uh
the coefficient describes
the the kth coefficient
of function fj
in
the frame fk
so
now applying u
to this whole x
you will act on each f j
and so
one is going to get the following
expression it's just d j k multiplying
cj's which are the coefficients of the
original state and so now you see that
it's basically a matrix operation so the
coupon operator now becomes this matrix
djk
and you multiply that with coefficient
cj and you get x prime that describes
p prime really
so that's
what it means to exhibit the operator in
some in some basis
and you can see that this nonlinear
potentially non-linear dynamics
is represented entirely linearly
here
right as a as a matrix operation
so that's
one of the new things that happened
in the last um
let's say uh 20 years or so maybe 20 30
years or so that we realize that we can
you know do some applied whatever i
would say applied mathematics
um
for this operating in in the context
that we approximate it in in a certain
in a certain basis
so um
let's go back a little bit and say okay
if you have that representation and you
have an observable g
one of the ideas here
is
i could utilize the eigen functions
to understand how different parts of the
systems interact and that
um
expansion is now called the kukman mode
decomposition
so if you take an arbitrary vector
observable
g that are functions of z that's a field
variable let's say you're looking at a
fluid flow this would be a point in
space and an x
which is a state space
state space variable
then it can be split into the time
average which is the g star that depends
on this field variable
and then something some components that
grow decay
or oscillate exponentially
complex exponentials obviously
multiplied by an eigen function
and then this projection
is really a projection onto coupon modes
that as i said you can actually do
directly from data without integrating
over a very high dimensional space
that's one of the tricks that is very
useful but then you have this part and
that's the part
that is the continuous spectrum if you
have chaotic dynamics in your system or
noise
there is going to be continuous spectrum
and very often in computational work
today this is neglected
um it really shouldn't be there are a
few theoretical works that have appeared
recently that that treat it and provide
provide also
numerical methods
but one of the ways you can look at this
decomposition into the time average
growing decaying oscillating modes and
continuous spectrum is really
a decomposition of dynamics into
coherent parts and
continuous continuous spectrum parts or
quality frequency noisy but that
includes chaotic dynamics as well
so
examples of this is what i've shown you
at the beginning these you know modes
here sjs are modes phi js are eigen
functions so there is this triple eigen
values
modes eigen functions
so
these
shapes that are associated with that jet
when you sum up over these and a bunch
of other stuff that includes some
continuous spectrum we actually get back
the whole dynamics of of the jet so if
you pick up these eigenvalues here
correspond to the slower evolution this
is this mode
and faster evolution that is that that
mode
so there are just some but of course you
see many more objects here and then you
see this pale stuff in the spectrum and
that is really the continuous spectrum
part
now you can play this game in in a large
variety of applications i'm pulling out
some that we've been associated with
uh we've designed or rather utilize
these methods for building energy
efficiency for example this gives you a
mode that reflects the temperature
evolution in a room over a 24-hour time
scale so it's a daily period mode
um
power grids i'll show you some examples
of that as we go
uh this is a picture a heat map of a 24
hour mode of a network on the horizontal
axis there is ips label is is just
numbers and on a vertical axis the same
set of ips and if you're seeing red in
this mode that is plotted as a
as a heat map
that means that
that pair
this ip
and that ip
are
corresponding
perhaps during the daily office hours
nine to six
and then are shutting down during the
night time
as you might imagine
um if
if uh you don't see any if on some days
you see this happening and then suddenly
they're chatting all the time there
might be actually a problem uh so you
can see how this could potentially be
applied to security and if you're
interested in how this is applied in the
context of network security look up the
website there it's
it's a
kind of an interesting application
that that really works on the basis of
what i mentioned
and that is the spectral analysis where
you don't need to necessarily exhibit
the operator
all right so let's talk a little bit
about eigenfunctions because i want to
give you
an impression of
of the mathematical
properties of these eigen functions
because at this point you could ask
yourself well
um
this is an infinite expansion in
principle k can go to infinity so
isn't this you know very complex i i'd
say potentially but of course we do
basis expansions in
in
in many different contexts so we cut off
at the finite size equipment operator
provides us with something better it
actually provides us with
the ability to get
an infinite number of eigenfunctions
from a finite one but for that i need to
go into a little bit of theory
so the eigenfunctions of the coupon
operator have really nice algebraic
properties namely what this proposition
tells you is that if you're in a
particular
particularly defined space
so it's it's a vector space closed it's
under point-wise products of functions
so it's an algebra and then you have a
constant function in it
the constant function needs to be there
all the time that's kind of a trivial
requirement
then the set of eigenfunctions forms
what is called an a billion monoid what
this really means
is that if you have two eigenfunctions
in that space then their product is an
eigenfunction as well
so that's useful
[Music]
that's quite useful
the reason being that let's say you have
linear systems
in which geometric multiplicity is equal
to algebraic multiplicity i don't know
why this is sitting here you can
explicitly find the eigenfunctions that
inner products of x with the left
eigenvectors of a
you can find explicitly an expansion for
a linear system here are the eigen
functions here are the eigenvalues
they're really coupon eigenvalues and
now the eigenvalues of the matrix as
well and here are the modes there are
familiar notions eigen their
eigenvectors
so
you see in this case the expansion is
finite
so if you have a linear system
on a linear space of observables
so
only the states themselves and the span
of these
equations describing uh observables
describing the the state
then the expansion is finite
you can do a variety of things if you're
interested in dynamical systems then
instead of looking at eigenvectors you
can look at eigenfunctions as
geometrical objects in order to
understand the state space but
interestingly even if you go
to uh
to the non-linear case
in particular the first nonlinear case
that you can think of
is when the observable itself is
non-linear a nonlinear functional state
you can define this phi 1 to phi d where
that is the dimension of the linear
system now
as principal eigen functions and as i
said before you can get all the other
eigenfunctions from these
d ones
and your expansion
is predicated which now is infinite so
the expansion or the evolution in time
of
a vector observable
is now infinite
but it really contains products of a
finite number of principal eigen
functions
so and this is a very general theme in
coupon operator theory if you find
principal eigenfunctions that are
associated with an attractor
then all the other information flows
from it
so in many cases it is actually a finite
dimensional theory
meaning
you have
a
lossless encoder in machine learning
terms
if you find phi 1 to phi d
you can recover the state
just from that information perfectly
if i'm to put this in machine language
right
so these mathematical aspects
differentiate
coupon operator theory as a learning
framework
from for example
deep learning
where
the underlying theory is actually
largely lacking
we don't have it there are a lot of
efforts around the world
in in order to put it in place
and interestingly
of course deep learning is based on the
same
operator if you think about it the layer
to layer operation in deep learning is
com is is a composition operation
by the way that's why it works
so well this is a side side comment and
maybe a little bit cryptic so if anybody
would like to discuss that after the
talk i'm i'm happy to do it
but that's why it's so efficient as a
functional approximation
but here we have a very precise theory i
literally just gave you a theorem that
says that
that i can have a lossless autoencoder
of a nonlinear system
that
that is of a of a nonlinear observation
on a linear system
um
you know that is of the dimension uh d
which is the dimension of the linear
system itself
so here is the point knowing and eigen
eigenfunctions we get all of them i've
tried to put this in the encoder terms
so um
another important thing that you can do
with this theory is
understanding of which systems are
similar or whether you're observing the
same system using you know a few
different observables
um this is important in context of data
fusion
let's say that you're observing a system
with a set of variables x and a set of
variables y
and x is governed by some dynamics f of
x and y dot is some g of y they have the
associated flows t for y and s
so
you could
show that the two systems are
practically the same they're the same
evolution
if you found
a mapping h
from one system to another
such that if you apply h to the
evolution of x
you get
the evolution of y
applied to h it's a commutative diagram
it basically means here's the x system
here is the y system the x system flows
forward the y system flows forward if
you map
x by h
and then flow forward by y it's exactly
the same as
mapping forward by x and then flowing by
h
so the two systems are basically doing
doing the same thing and a nice little
proposition that we proved some some
years ago
says that um
gives the condition
under which this is true using some
classical dynamical systems theorems it
says that you can find that different
morphism
um
under the condition that for example
hartmann groban theorem
locally holds
um a bigger picture story is that the
eigenvalues of the kupman operator which
in this case are connected to local
eigenvalues close to the fixed point
if you find that they are the same for
two systems
then those two systems are connected by
a simple transformation they're just a
an image of each other and not different
systems really this is the whole notion
of conjugacy which as i said
can be and we did
with the
uh you know with the joint work with the
unesco bikinis and others
used in data fusion
um
now
non-linear systems so i i the first
nonlinear thing that i did is i i took a
look at a
linear system with nonlinear observables
but here i have a general nonlinear
system and you see now that the
expansion is very similar how so
it is something that looks like
eigenvectors in the linear systems these
are really modes
s1 to sn are principal eigen functions
of the operator that can be obtained by
conjugacy from the linear system
these are the powers k1 to kn
and then the evolution
is really the time evolution multiplied
by this
i
eigenvalue integer combination so you
multiply the first eigenvalue with
integer second and so on
so
again if you know s1 to sn
k1 to kn are just integers lambda 1 to
lambda n are eigenvalues
of a finite of a finite
you know linearization matrix and then
you get a global
expansion that looks something like this
you have to be a bit careful because
when you have expansions like this
they are power expansions right they
almost look like a taylor
taylor series in this part here and so
there could be an electricity breakdown
and that happens in numerical methods
paige and kurzweil had some really nice
papers on this
where they discovered that yes
the expansion
does hold but of course it breaks down
numerically
because of the analyticity properties of
the underlying on the underlying
evolution so
again you know the theoretical aspects
come into picture very strongly but they
help you because they you can understand
where the numerical analysis is solid
and where
and where it could potentially
potentially break down
you know the next step up in complexity
after
uh fixed point systems are systems with
limit cycle are the most famous ones is
this so plunder pole oscillator the
first two equations if you neglect the
the non-linear term is just a harmonic
oscillator x1 dot is x2 x2 dot is minus
x1 right
this is a nonlinear damping forcing term
so mu x2
is a is a is really
a forcing and then mu
x1 squared x2 with a minus is a
non-linear damping
the balance of the forcing and damping
uh
interacts in such a way that the system
has a periodic limit cycle so the
forcing and damping when they average
when their average over over a cycle is
is is equal
they balance each other and you
end up in a perpetual oscillation such
systems can be
transformed not in the y dot is a of y
form but something similar y dot is a of
sy where s is a variable in a circle and
spins continuously so you find
eigenfunctions for this
you will find eigenfunctions for the
whole system
and that again is helpful
um
here
is is the general expansion
for uh 2d systems
uh you know limit cycling to these
systems
and then the next slide is the general
expansion of limit cycling and and
dimensions and you see the same kind of
uh a
a a principle
there are products of
of uh principal eigen functions
then there are
eigenvalues and eigenvalues consist of
some integers times the
the basic exponents of the linearization
around the attractor
um
and the on attractor evolution
so
there is a very general picture of what
happens in the coherent part remember
the
remember the
the splitting spectral splitting into
the coherent part which is oscillating
decaying growing
so that was
a coherent dynamics
and then the continuous spectrum part
which is chaotic dynamics so we we have
in common operator theory a way of
splitting the coherent parts of dynamics
and continuous part of dynamics and by
the way just a side comment i'll make a
number of references to machine learning
in this context
that helps with uh
with not having overfitting
because the noisy part is separated out
in the continuous spectrum and that's
the part you don't want to learn
using eigenfunctions in fact
eigenfunctions for such systems
don't exist
so you're not doing
overfitting when you actually represent
the system
using eigenfunctions for example
we will not want
to represent the continuous spectrum
part of the system
using some coherent
you know approximation
and as you as i'm sure you all know that
is a serious problem in machine
in in deep learning in general
so uh here is the eigenvalue plot and
this is very general for the coherent
part it's basically a lattice this for a
stable system the lattice of eigenvalues
lives in the left half plane
so the point i was making before is if
you
if you measure
remember all this is available from data
so if you measure system one
and system and then measure again with
other observables and you update the
same spectrum you know you're measuring
the same system or if you want to fuse
the data this is a good check
that your data is actually
that your data is actually coherent
all right so as i mentioned one of the
interesting applications here and by the
way how much time do i have at this
point
you have 10 10 minutes okay so i'll go
into applications here so that's that's
i think going to be enough i'd like to
show you one that we've done very
recently uh one of the interesting
applications here of course and and uh
and the
field that's uh
that's getting more and more attention
is application of of this in the context
of control systems so now of course
besides your variables x you have u
which is the control and u lives in its
own space in this case we set it as rm
you can write this control system
as a dynamical system actually if you
propose dynamics for you so then
you has its own dynamics represented
this map s
you can envision it as just having a
sequence of control inputs and just
shifting them to the left and then
picking
on the input at uh at exactly position
position zero the point that i want to
make is that in fact there is a way by
which
a control system can be considered as a
dynamical system of the type that we
call skew product systems
and this is uh
joint work with with milan corda there
is some prior work
on control
using kubeman operators that is also
listed here
okay
so now we have the data
at time t
the data at time t
t plus one
and then we know there is some dynamics
nonlinear dynamics that ports the data
at time t
to time t plus one but
we are going to look at
forming observables remember the basis
functions for example that i that i
mentioned at the beginning in the intro
and we are going to try to minimize
the difference between the the
observations so these are the
observables that you're embedding your
state observations
with so for example you could have
uh
chi i and then chi i squared or sine of
chi right some library some basis and
then a is the matrix that is the
representation that matrix djk the
representation of the coupon operator
acting on the on the previous time data
and i'd like to minimize this over all
the matrices of a selected dimension
this dimension here is a hyper parameter
so we also are going to ask that our
predictor is linear in u this is
actually in general the formalism leads
to bi-linear equations but so this is an
assumption
and uh the lifting
here is very simple
we'll we'll take some library of
functions in the state space and then
we'll basically take the control inputs
at a specific time we are looking
looking at so control inputs at the
specific time zero this can be extended
and we just did in some work that we're
doing on
on uh soft robotics that
you know because of time i don't have a
chance to present
uh here
but we want to minimize
over all
matrices a and so this original problem
of calligraphic a can be represented as
minimizing over all matrices a and b
such that the observables at the next
time state of zero was in the next time
minus a of zeros at the previous time
minus b times control inputs
is is a minimum
so that's the idea so here is the
algorithm
you take
the x data
the data the next time
the inputs
you lift it
you formula the least squares problem
and then the least squares problem has
of course the standard solution using
more penrose more penrose inverse
and then you get a linear system
well it's a linear system that's
possibly of much higher dimension than
your original nonlinear system but it's
still a linear system and you can design
controllers based on linear
based on linear
control ideas as we did in this
automatica 2018 paper you can use a
variety of things we used mpc
lqr has been tried in the meantime h
infinity has been tried it's interesting
to look at you know what a local
linearization
would do so see blue is the true
evolution dynamical evolution of the
pendulum
green is when we locally linearize
around the fixed point and then
and then the red is what you get with
this kupman
type
predictor in time
uh it solves a convex quadratic problem
so it's it's it's um
[Music]
it's um
reliable and fast and it's completely
data driven there is no underlying model
that that is associated with it
um
here is an example that we did
this is a fluid flow the observations
are only done on these x
points here the lid on the top is moving
and so here the control is trying to
move the lid to get rid of the
oscillations you have all experienced
this problem i think if you open the
windows in your car
and it was you're driving fast enough
and then you get this boom boom boom
boom boom
oscillations right of the fluid so it's
a it's a lid
uh
over a cavity
in the flow over cavity that causes
bifurcation
and fast oscillations we want to get rid
of those
and here is a movie that's going to show
you
if you're seeing the vanishing of red
and blue that's the vanishing of the
vorticity associated with the
oscillations so when you see it
completely white that means that it's
controlled to a state that doesn't have
any oscillation so we got rid of
oscillations
uh what's interesting the coupon
controller comes up with this really
interesting
interesting uh
this is the this is the control versus
time it comes with this really
interesting
um
[Music]
algorithm
where you see that the
lid is moved periodically so here is
the movement of the lid here is the
movement here is a movement and it's
very physically natural
the reason being that
if you saw the flow here
goes around so what happens is that as
a chunk of vorticity comes up
the motion is opposed to it and just
knows it
it's very physical in the way
it does things and so this is something
i'd like to
point out as well
the
learning control ai based on equipment
operator theory is very explainable you
can literally look at the matrix
that i mentioned at the beginning and
understand what the coefficients are
saying who is interacting with who
in the function space
you know as opposed to
and in deep learning of course the
coefficients
are local
and so
they don't have any kind of global
interpretation
and that's certainly been a problem
for uh for interpreting things
physically i tend to say
if you're modeling a physical process
the operator is the physics
and therefore it's it's
its
coefficients are in fact
explainable
all
right so
the other place where we um
utilize this is in power grid this is a
northeastern power grid with 10
generators
we were interested in
uh
invariant sets
in this case
an invariant set you know is the state
stable domain the color scheme is a
little bit opposite to what it should be
the the red domain here is stable
and you've seen an instability in this
in simulation of this
system
uh on the right
and so the question was can we use the
coupon operator methods in this space
where we you know we have a pretty high
dimensional space
20 plus dimensions plus hybrid dynamics
to detect invariant sets
it turns out
that level sets
of
coupon eigenfunctions at
zero
in fact give you in variance sets
this might sound abstract
it's actually very easy to connect to
something that i think everybody in the
call knows which is
the level sets of energy in a
in a conservative system
are invariant sets
so this is the same idea it's just more
general it doesn't have to be energy
uh in this particular case cinemarian
said that is a you're looking at a
projection on a two-dimensional coarse
grained variables in a 20-dimensional
space so you know a wide
extension of the original idea but
basically the same concept
so that's something that we've applied
things to we've also
uh looked at individual modes and you
know this was the use of eigenfunctions
we looked at individual modes in the
power grid with this is all
collaboration with your professor suzuki
from
osaka and professor hikihara
at kyoto
we looked at the modes and then the
modes evolve as i pointed out before you
know in a very
simple
manner in time
it's one of the one of the advantages of
the coupon operator theory is that it
doesn't attempt to represent
the dynamics in time with some you know
lstms or whatever
it actually
says well dynamical processes in time
evolve
you know according physical processes
very often according to oscillations
growing or decaying and that's how it
represents them so you can say well if i
have oscillating but not linear dynamics
maybe i can plot the amplitude and phase
of these modes collect them
and see whether i have any coherency in
power grid the problem is detecting the
coherency of various generators in a
white you know in a distributed network
so here you are seeing the two three six
seven and nine
form one block and then two
to seven nine and ten another block so
what should be
is that
that two three
uh
two and three
and seven six and seven form one
coherent set and that's indeed what what
happens in the dynamics so um i'm gonna
close that i think i'm hopefully
just a few minutes
just a few minutes over time i want to
leave you with some conclusions
i hopefully described
the theory underlying the
the
equipment operator
uh framework
um
i stress the eigen importance of
eigenvalues and why they are useful for
example in data fusion the eigen
functions to understand the state space
aspects the modes to understand the
global dynamics aspects
uh for example like coherence in power
grid
but what i want to stress more than
pretty much anything else in this talk
is that it does provide us with a
powerful learning framework
even for dynamical systems that are as
complicated as the starcraft game
and even you know
substantially more complicated than that
one that we have done that we have done
in the meantime
so um as far as dynamics processes are
concerned while we use deep learning to
learn the elements of the kupman
representation that's that's a nice and
and and
that's a nice setup there is a nice set
of works out there
that speaks to that so we're not shying
away from using machine learning as a
functional approximation aspect of this
it does seem
that it's explicit treatment of time
as a separate you know as a separate
dimension it's explicit treatment of
time evolution and underst
its inherent you know automatic
understanding of the underlying dynamics
gives it an edge
over other approaches to dynamical
systems learning today
and
that's what i'm
close with and see if there are any
any questions to follow
thank you thank you
thank you so much for the great talk
igor um absolutely
well you were right on time you didn't
go over time it's eleven
eight eleven a.m and we usually go
um
you know later than 11 a.m okay so let's
have a cranial session from gabrielle
could you elaborate on your earlier
point about function composition and the
efficiency of the deep learning
can you hear me read that gabriel
yes could you elaborate on your earlier
uh points about the function composition
and the efficiency of the deep learning
right
okay so this is really an interesting
question
so um
when when you take a look at
the coupon operator evolution it's also
governed by composition so for example
your observable gets composed with the
mapping t in the first step
and then in the second step you compose
twice with the mapping t and then the
third step twice right and if the
dynamics is sufficiently complicated
the original function however smooth it
is it could be something like as simple
as a sinusoid you know on on an interval
if if your mapping is something like x
prime is 2x mod 1 something chaotic
the the features that the
function f after many iterations is
going to
have
are very arbitrary and can represent
you know pretty much any point on the
unit interval what i'm trying to point
out is that the composition itself is a
very efficient way of creating new
information from old provided that the
underlying operator is
is rich enough
and the deep learning provides us with
operators of course it's a little bit
different because it's layer to layer
dynamics of composition is is can be
different because layers could be
potentially different
but the reason in my view why it's so
efficient and could be potentially
exponentially efficient as as the kupman
is
a is that
that that
provides this richness of information
from layer to layer
i hope that
answers the question
okay
that's great
next question is from elon
joseph thank you for the great talk
real world systems usually have a
chaotic dynamics can you say more about
the treatment of the
uh yeah
so yes spectrum yes
great again thanks for that question
because it follows up very closely on on
that the composition that then i end up
talking about modes and eigenfunctions
which is used most today
there is this part that's called
that that is the continuous spectrum
that you can specifically decouple
from the
from the coherent part a we've developed
ourselves
methods to extract coherent
i would call them pseudoeigen functions
from continuous spectrum
i can send you the paper if you're
interested
using a class of methods that don't
exhibit the operator so these strictly
spectral
you know
basically related to weighted time
averages along trajectories so we don't
need to exhibit the matrix itself so
that's one way of getting them
um so there is coherence in the
continuous part of the spectrum you
might have
pseudo-eigenvalues
pseudo-eigenfunctions
that are there and so
i'll leave it there maybe at the
intuitive level a dimitrij genearchies
group at nyu has also discovered some of
these elements
using compactification methods and
kernel methods so those are the two sets
of papers at this point in time that i'm
aware of to deal with it i just got on
my screen yesterday another paper from a
cambridge cornell collaboration
that also deals with it but i didn't
have a chance to read it yet so i'll
have a little bit more when that happens
but uh
but elon if if you're interested send me
an email and i will just send you the
papers
very great i'm i'm very curious
great joseph i'm very interested in
continuous spectrum also um
some of the the data we get from the
all-skate simulation it um it has a
continuous spectrum so
um
yeah i will email you
after that me too on the analysis side i
think this is the the most interesting
remaining part so i advocated a lot for
control and
i advocated quite a bit for learning
but uh but there is one item that we
still need to know more about
and that i grappled with from you know
2005 favor where i proposed the way of
treating the continuous spectrum
um
and now we have even you know certainly
better ways and clearer thinking but
more work needs to be done and more
applications need to be looked at in
this sense too often this is just swept
under the carpet people just say oh let
me assume i have an expansion that
doesn't include continuous spectrum yeah
that's a big assumption yeah yeah it is
all right another question from uh
sam
can you can we say the kunman operator
is more general version of svd or pca
what is the advantage of using command
operator
so a quick answer is no
it is not a more than original svd or pc
they're they're completely different in
fact
[Music]
svd has to so equipment operator in
principle is
not self-adjoint
uh
what one does in svd
or pca for that matter
is it symmetrizes whatever
non-self-adjoining matrix is and
provides a spectral decomposition of
that symmetrized version
information is lost
for a non-self-adjoint operator if you
do that
even if you have a self-adjoint operator
there are advantages of applying the the
kupman operator framework in the sense
that you have this you get a strict
dynamical evolution using eigenvalues so
a specific example is in fluid mechanics
where
svd or
pcas is called the proper terminal
decomposition
when you
analyze a fluid dynamics flow using that
you get spatially orthogonal modes
and then the dynamics the time dynamics
can be very complicated
the koopman
decomposition is orthogonal in time
not in space
and for a dynamical systems person
a
if you take a look at the simplest
dynamical system in 2d
let's say x dot is ax
with some matrix a which is two by two
the decomposition that the dynamical
system person is going to do
is going to be
the eigenvalue decomposition that i
showed
which is the dynamics is going to
present it as e to the lambda 1t
v1 which is the eigenvector number one
plus e to the lambda 2t v2 which is
eigenvector number two the eigenvectors
v1 and v2
are not in general orthogonal
those are the spatial components
and we wouldn't want it any other way
because orthogonalizing messes up the
time dynamics so it's actually a very
important question
because it points out why
the kupman operator framework is so
effective
in modeling the dynamical processes it
has the right attitude towards time i
hope that answers the question
okay that sounds good i well that brings
me
another question from my side but let's
go over
other people's questions
the badlos asks is your oh
sorry federer says is your command mode
decomposition different than
what dmd or its newer variants can do
or where is svd hidden in your scheme
after all dmd is strictly
spd based
this enables me to clarify quite a bit
further
dmd
that peter schmidt invented completely
independently of the cookman of the
coopman world
is in fact in certain situations related
to kupman operator theory and in fact
provides a numerical algorithm
for finding the eigenvalues and
and and modes
of the coupon operator
so
let me just summarize this
dmd is one of the many
now but the dominant one
uh ways of approximating the equipment
operate
the way svd is used in dmd
is to provide
a
basis
remember f1 f2 to fn those bases so you
start with a certain basis
that is given from whatever data you
have
you then use fsvd there
to find another basis that hopefully
contains more information and coarse
grained information
so that's how svd is used basically
for coarse graining in dmd
i i do have to mention this
idiosyncratic point of view i'm i'm
explaining this from
a perspective that's described in my
paper numerical analysis equipment
operators it's an archive so better if
you want i'll send it to you
but uh
and and battles are saying what what
does svd do to the continued spectrum
in general it kills it
and that's why
that's why when you do want to
address
the you know the coupon operator
decomposing or coupon mode decomposition
in its totality
we really need to go beyond
dmd
uh one of the ways of doing this is just
you know the the reason svd was
introduced by peter you know brilliantly
into in into dmv
was to make sure that the
the
numerix is in in fact
robust
right
so that the
[Music]
conditioning of the matrix
is correct so it was really a numerical
approach very very very nice nicely done
but it does something
when you
you know something that that is not
necessarily good
when you think of it in context of
kukman and and bedros just
whether it's just uh a you know pointed
out in no unclear terms
um
[Music]
that is a problem
um
we had some papers with zlatka dermatome
from zagreb
um
it is really his algorithm uh the the
wonder monkushi
approach that that deals with the same
problem without really cutting
things off
and
this might be another way forward but
now by now there are you know three
different ways forward on continuous
spectrum
um so i'm quite hopeful that
you know in the next couple of years
we're going to have
a very robust set of ideas on on how to
how to compute and how to make sure
we're not missing anything
all right great um the next question
from ellen
a finite dimensional approximation of
the kuhman operator can only have one
attractor however a dynamical system
might have more than one attractor which
leads to bifurcation phenomena does this
limit the applicability of the model for
studying bifurcation dynamics
great question uh i'll start with a
simple answer no
it doesn't limit
uh for any dynamical system with however
many
attractors it has
the kupman operator does contain
all the information about
all the attractives so you can basically
recover the dynamics
perfectly
if you know the operator perfectly right
so then the question uh comes to what
has been done
in this context and how people looked at
it
so
what's really interesting is that
whenever bifurcation happens
in any part of the state space
the coupon operator is going to have
some eigen values that have zero real
part
so you can certainly study
bifurcations in the context
of the kupman of the cookman operator
itself
when you look at the problems in which
there are transitions between different
attractors that's also very interesting
and under simple expansions like i did
or maybe complex in theory but but
relatively simple as is because they
have a form of taylor exam taylor
expansions just in terms of eigen
functions can fail because of
analyticity properties that was the
paper of page and cursive that i
mentioned
and in that case on the numerical side
one needs to be really careful and
people are working on that
as well as we speak i should say that
besides continuous spectrum this is also
really interesting
a really interesting um
you know theoretical and question what
the analysis can advance advance further
um but uh interestingly at the
bifurcation points you usually have
appearance of continuous spectrum as
well so the two are connected
thanks for that question great question
okay great um
okay next one is not a question but it's
a comments by
bob blake um
orthogonal in time seems to be the
takeaway i think so also related to that
i have a question i have my own
questions
you know going back to the svd
so let's say you have a simulation data
and you apply um the svd to get for
example pod modes
from the flow data you have flow
dynamical data you have
the left singular
matrix
from that svdt composition holds a
spatial
you know the most but if you look at the
right singular
matrix it does hold a temporal mode
corresponding to each spatial mode and
that describes a temporal
mode of the
you know the individual spatial modes
how it behaves etc
and you could
take extract those right singular matrix
and then
uh combine them so that is also analyze
and come up with the also on a temporal
basis of individual uh
spatial modes so
it doesn't describes the whole you know
it doesn't go into the temporal modes
directly but it goes through
spatial modes
so
maybe you know so there's some
connection between the command operator
and the svd in that sense
there is a there is a little
theorem that you can prove i never
published it really
it describes precisely
when the
um
the
uh pod modes or you know proper dollar
acquisition modes or pca
and coupon modes are the same
and that's in the case when you
basically have a linear system or a
linear representation
and
and the modes are
normal
there are
a large number of works in which
you know some kind of combinations are
pursued of the two
i would say the first thing to try
any new method on is literally the
problem that i mentioned
with a linear system
two by two matrix
and
non-orthogonal eigenvectors
and one immediately sees how much more
complex
is to do
pca or rather understand
what the system does
in the pca representation
rather than in the kuman representation
in the coupon representation
it is basically the same as what we know
it's an eigenvector expansion
the pca representation mixes the
eigenvectors
and that
uh
you know to me at least i look i've been
trained in dynamical systems
so to me
that mixes things up
the place where
the
you know the the place where the pca
comes from really
is from analysis of stochastic processes
in which orthogonalization
in space
is a
very desirable property
um
and i myself argued that for example
aspects of continuous spectrum that have
no features like there are no pseudo
eigen functions or anything like that
you could effectively use the pod on
actually in the original paper on coupon
mode deposition in o5 if you take a look
at the
last section and conclusions it it says
precisely that
but that's the situation in which you
have no coherent part
anytime there is a coherent and one
needs to extract that anytime there is a
coherent part in my view
applying the pod before you've extracted
the query part
is going to confuse things up
dynamically speaking
got it right okay
thank you so much um um
yeah
i don't think i have any more questions
except the rap
comment out i think that would make
sense you to be equivalent to saying all
eigenvectors are also going on if your
linear system is symmetric
yeah yeah so in that case
uh it's you know the the two methods end
up being the same you can prove it it's
not very hard
but i've never published it probably i
should have maybe i should publish it
just as a as a little note because it
would clarify some of these questions
but um
but my remark stands right so when the
dynamical system has coherent features
and the
the um
eigenfunctions are not
orthogonal
then
[Music]
probably the the equipment framework is
the
efficient one to go with
all right
okay sounds good um
i don't see any more questions well we
have like 20 minutes past the 11 but we
we usually do so don't feel bad igor
it's it means a lot of people are
interested in your work
and
well let's thank uh igor uh it's uh it
was wonderful talk and i think
a lot of people appreciate it
very well thank you so much let's let's
thank eagle of the speaker today for the
wonderful talk and
wonderful q a session thank you so much
for having me i really appreciated
some great questions
yeah yeah
all right with that let's um
let's conclude uh except elon said if
the linear system can be presented as a
normal matrix
a dagger equals zero
um
i was just commenting on the last
comment just that that's that's the
condition for which the eigenvectors
become orthogonal
practically yes
yes all right sounds good all right uh
shall we um
finish up thank you thank you so much um
and um
keep in touch igor um and i need the i
need your um
what is it the pdf